i mean bob almost got possessed by a
ghost at our powerhouse
like he had to jump in the swimming pool
to get them off of him
now were you guys doing drugs at this
time no my first thought
a lot of whites and chin back there and
we have cb
yeah i was just saying kind of
definitely a lot of whites
yeah jeremiah you got was jeremiah just
here for support
i don't know i thought it was going to
be honest i know i thought it was going
to be okay
it was a surprise this is like an
american idol audition
you know how so because jeremiah's like
steve's mom and she's back there
all right all right
my baby dave you're doing great honey
you're doing great honey okay
it was the voice because the parents
would be like he's working so hard at
this
yeah this is his dream that's my
composure that's my baby right there
and then when they're death's
turnarounds
not my soccer mom man not my soccer mom
man supportive friend
dude i uh support a friend nobody's more
supportive
than me mister i know okay i never said
you weren't
come on yeah there's an undertone come
on you look a little uh
tired heard you were in uh washington
visiting a friend i knew you were gonna
bring that up
what's up with the bait and switch stuff
too you guys doing stuff on me no not at
all that was all you darling
wait wait wait wait i need to know about
this who are you visiting in washington
yeah worry about it
female friend wand we took southwest up
there
a female friend i don't miss anything
yeah alaskan airlines
it was a good trip it was fun how long
were you up there just for a day or two
is it pretty serious no we're just
having fun we're having fun wait did you
did you break up with your girl fill
them in
filament you don't you don't talk to me
anymore you got your little podcast with
your liar
that's my baby up there he doesn't even
hit me up anymore i don't i don't know
anything about him anymore we gotta get
you on war zone though
what's warzone because i did your show
no no no no no no we're not gonna we're
not gonna don't let him down we're gonna
talk about it so you broke up with
your girl wow he broke up with her comes
on here
we line up basically blind dates for him
dime pieces right he's like okay this
sounds cool
hot hot girls everybody oh no they were
attractive they were so attractive but
he found a hood rat in washington
bro comes back to the next episode comes
back to the next episode
he's supposed to go on a date with all
these girls there's a hickey on his neck
steve don't mess around that's why
all right and we're like you don't mess
around we're like all right well i
missed that
baby can we start over guys no let's
get a hook let's start i'm proud of you
i just wish you were upfront about it i
still got my toys i got my tanga egg
i got my butt i got my flashlight you've
been to my place yeah it's a nice place
yeah
wait that's good you've been to steve's
place yeah all right let's not start
there guys please
so you so you had you guys how about we
do a segment break down my apartment
cause you got y'all both been there well
i told you
i want honesty no no i totally get why
you flew to washington and didn't bring
her here
i mean that would make sense but she's
been but she's been here
yeah yeah but break down my apartment
what's her name
you know that's not her name yeah but
thank you
thank you but what this is her uh
these are the young ladies who found out
he had a girl and their heart broken
um okay
this is amanda she was bodied i'm a
little sad
about stevie's change of heart honestly
wow um
i've been keeping up on each episode
hoping that change of heart i don't know
who this lady is from washington but
apparently him her sucking on his neck
is uh
far better than whatever he's imagined i
don't know
but uh yeah
i'm super super sad so
all right bye guys she looks sad she
looks legit sad
are you really though she's so pretty
too are you really you know what
i cut in steve's defense are you really
i'm with steve on there
this is some cloud chasing like look at
this smile right here i see
evilness right here like let's focus in
on that yeah she's all right
you didn't see her original submission
though she was she was the one from
montana that i kept pushing stevie
towards because some of the other girls
uh some of the other suitors we may have
reached out and asked them to
but she was the first one and she was
very serious about it stevie
she lives in montana yeah yeah but she's
down she can get it can we get an la
chick
for steve well look where i live guys
you've seen where i live it's a nice
place but it's about you
i i think you're i don't know no i'm i
really like a flying man
wrong with it no i'm sw for reals
see i could see i swear to god i thought
it was a cool like
very la place go ahead keep going no i'm
serious
keep going look like you said a big
trouble in a little china it was [ __ ] it
was lit
it was cool keep going i liked it yeah
i'm serious
if it was connected to like a donut shop
laundry mat yeah maybe
you go in the bag see now you're talking
reality
no i thought it was cute though you did
so well you know what though
honestly steve i didn't know that that
had happened and uh but you seem
you seem to be happier now so we got to
the root cause of he's like playing
video games eight hours a day not giving
her any attention
messing with this fake butt that he has
all the time instead of hooking up with
her if not you know i'll just wait for a
robot
i'll wait for the robots to come you
know i'll get a female robot
you know i appreciate this though but
hey if she was really interested
in me then she'd hit my dms right no
true
that's a fair point going through the
kingdom sting and not going directly to
stevie
yeah i agree with that that's a fair
point the exposure on
there so we're putting it out there
right now that's what it is you know get
to know me
la ladies hit up the dms but are you
taking what are you taking now
what no no yeah i'm just i'm dating man
i'm dancing so you should but you can
date others
yeah i'm not going to commit i mean i'm
dating yeah she's in washington
she's
yeah so shout out to sellers calzone by
washington state university oh wow
um yeah there's a walmart in town it's a
it's a whole thing
small town yeah but you could go you
could see other people
yeah i mean it's not i'm not in like
committed
you know i was in a four and a half five
year thing i'm aware
yeah would she be upset if she heard you
say that
i mean i'll we'll talk i mean you know
i'm gonna hear it yeah
yeah well she might you guys have a lot
of fun let's see we've got her on the
line right now
and her mom's here too come on in yeah
come on wait what did you just say
no just kidding i get a ptsd when i come
here man
can we talk about the real about the
bait and switch because i agreed to do
the dating thing but i
i was reluctant i'm like oh i'll go
along with it but i'm kind of seeing
someone
i went along with it because of the
content and the entertainment value
and all that so it wasn't a big switch
and on top of all that
me and theo were talking i wasn't even
here i know but i thought the cameras
were off
the cameras and i i've been getting
attacked brother
no yeah fans were mad more
their attack that you should your dad
should have killed you
you look like an alien if it wasn't for
your brother
you would be just they were mad like
long paragraphs oh they were mad that
you
and they're fans of you you know what i
like about this right now stevenson is
like wwf wrestling voice right now yeah
it's because of you brother
you brother
i want you to feel my pain yeah yeah
is it because of me because i wasn't in
there i was in here and i'm not in
charge of the campaign he's an aspiring
mma fighter i think it's because of you
really yeah
he's owned two well he's owned two
no the guy who's talking [ __ ] to him too
yeah i know i know
yeah he's your fan and they're mad
because they saw that outtake footage
yeah and it was just i was just being
funny and i was just being
you know we're just that's that's unfair
we were shooting the [ __ ] i mean
i mean it happened you know i was an
indian you were talking to theo i was in
i was in the bathroom oh so that's your
excuse
i had that you're gathering information
who's that hey what's steve saying who's
in charge
where does the buck stop that's what we
want to know the harry potter nick
so where are those those girls were
pissed that stevie's taken nick uh
they they all were a little disappointed
uh we also have they really though
what are they really the one for montana
i'm telling you stevie you could have
something with her
hold on a second uh hold on a second i'm
stepping in
what could he have with her a weekend
trip to montana every other month
i'm gonna go to a weekend trip to
montana bozeman's beautiful
it'd be great you could have calzones in
montana a ranch there ain't no calzones
ranch
what's going on here exactly it's a hot
area because this girl is from idaho
mm-hmm and she said let me just dude
don't be winking at me man
play the thing what's this about you
could just go washington idaho montana
hit all three of them steve this one
but this one looks like she got a pass
well she tells us about she was actually
on last week let's just see what she
told us what she said last week hey theo
hey brendan
it's savannah from out here in southern
idaho um
i have a little bit of a debate club
slash relationship advice for you guys
um me and my boyfriend of four years
just decided to
part ways a week ago after
i was ready to be wifed up and he
decided he didn't want to wife me up
so i'm going through a little bit of a
rut wondering if i should just keep it
tight
and look for that forever or if i should
have a whole face
so first of all go ahead
i remember this we said whole face hold
on does she look like somebody that
hasn't already had a whole face
i'm just saying she was in a four-year
relationship yeah
we everybody's had a whole face yeah i
think she might just say should i go
into a new hotel
should i do that yeah you know what you
do how about you take some time off
and just be by yourself yeah yeah uh
what we put it out
for her that we wanted to do a little
dating game with her and see if we could
match make but someone on the comments
said uh
it's only been one week why don't you
read the back of a cereal box or
something
because she's already looking she was
with the guy for four years but yeah and
is this the guy there
yeah i think that's him uh with on the
right
with brendan at their show that's in
utah that was the start
that's where that works yep no but check
this out when you've been
with somebody for four years and if if
you're in a relationship and you're
regularly doing certain things and that
just all of a sudden stops
you you you're still in a mode to be
like look i have sex all the time
i do things all the time and you want to
keep that going that's what you know
it's a whole face no but the reason why
that's the normal phase i
wouldn't have called a whole face that's
true that's that's the time to say
retract all that
the whole point is though when you're
with somebody
like like you're with somebody because
you trust them even if you don't
whatever your relationship level is if
you love or in love but
there's something about like knowing
okay i'm gonna be with just this person
you know so you don't get stds and all
that kind of i mean that's what that's
all about
she might be at an age where it's like
do you really want to go into a whole
phase
at this point in your life well i think
we're gonna help her out with her whole
face aren't we
well it could be submissions nick
whatever she's looking for we've got we
got a bunch of young gentlemen who are
going to shoot their shot with her
a lot of fans saw her like dude we'll
sign up for that but first we're gonna
bring her on and talk to her
we can ask her a couple questions oh
here she is oh
there you go eric what's up king of the
sting gang buzz buzz gang
gang watches watches listen
watches have a look in quality not any
watch i'm talking about movement watches
mvmt watches look and feel like they're
400
500 that you're getting at the
department stores but movement takes all
that out
at a fraction of the cost because it
comes straight to you there's no
middleman you get a beautiful watch ship
right to your door all right shipping is
free
if you don't love it ship it right back
you got nothing to lose man you got
nothing to lose
whatever you want they get that grizzly
brown watch in their lexi slim
collection
they got whatever you want they get the
minimal sports
dive watch you can go 100 meters deep
100 meters deep with a watch what's up
doug
at a fraction of the cost all these
other fancy watches
they even got blue light glasses you
spend all day in front of a computer
if you're looking at lenses or screens
your eyes start to strain not anymore
with these blue light glasses
if you want to elevate your look and
style that doesn't break the bank then
join the movement get 50
off today with free shipping free
returns by going to mbmt.com
kats again that's mvmt.com
cats you know two out of three men will
experience some form of hair loss not my
boy theo van
his hair is getting longer if you
haven't noticed he looks like an 80s
hairband
guy and his hair will not stop growing
good for him and my i don't have a hair
problem either but
nick does so there you go two out of
three will suffer from it but
only one of us out of three suffers from
hair loss and it's nick but he's keeping
us here now because he uses keeps
keep offers a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair all right it's low-cost
treatment start just ten dollars per
month
keeps offers generic versions discreet
little package nobody has to know you're
using stuff to keep your locks all right
keeps has more than five star reviews on
any of its competitors
prevention is key trims can take four to
six months to see results so act right
now
if you're ready to take action and get
your flow on with your hair go to
keeps.com kats
to receive your first month of treatment
for free that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
cats
to get your first month free keeps.com
cats what's up girl how you doing
i'm good how are you guys i'm good
good
um how's the single life going for you
it's pretty pretty okay
not good enough out there is it though
what
i mean i don't know maybe i just have
high standards there it is
there it is which is a good thing i
don't know she just admitted it right
there it's not rough out there you just
looking for who you looking for ryan
gosling
i mean it wouldn't be bad to meet ryan
gosling
are you on the are you on the dating
apps
i'm not i've never been and i i don't
know how to navigate them i just
i don't know if it's for me you just
swipe
i know but have you ever been to idaho
before
yeah yeah there's not much out here
that's fair you need to set the mile
radius to 250. yeah don't you have to
pay like premium for that
um so yeah i'm not paying for a dating
app
did you lose free did you know all his
and then you probably knew all his
friends and your friends knew his
friends and so it's probably like
the pool is probably really low right
now for you huh right because everybody
out there is like
either his friend or knows who he is or
yeah does he watch this show
he does not actually i'm the fan
people are saying they're like she knows
her boy watches the show but i'm
actually the fan
so i feel like she would kill it on
farmers only
just is that a real thing no he already
has all of that
property claims like
and stuff like that but okay yeah
savannah we're gonna play
uh like five or six submissions from
guys you're not gonna be able to see
them
and just from their description we're
gonna bring two of them on your
favorites and then
eric brendan and stevie will kind of
grill them for you can we give her a
little insight what they look like or uh
no let's do like the void this will be
blind submission right now all right
let's not be shallow what is up
my name is roland i am submitting a
video for a potential date with savannah
uh why i think i'd be a good day is one
i'm also from idaho
western part of idaho out of nampa not
vietnam
sorry theo um so our dates if we want to
meet up not very long to meet each other
two i am a twin so she's gonna get the
two for one deal
three i'm a wildland firefighter
currently stationed in moab utah
fighting fire here so protecting the
force and our number one priority
uh four this ain't no ordinary mustache
this is
down south tickler and five soldiers i
am not a freak like stevie weeby
i don't have one [ __ ] over the weekends
and i
currently do not have a baby on the way
love this guy hey why are you throwing
me under the bus man he's just saying
he's not you know he's not into that
weird [ __ ]
you don't have a baby on the way do you
no that's okay
hey you know what i like him he's a
handsome guy yeah
i like his mustache i like his mustache
yeah he hey you know not a bad looking
dude firefighter
seems to have his [ __ ] together he lives
okay he looks like the marlboro man
but two things i didn't like one that
he's
assuming that him and his twin brother
are going to be
you know with her at the same time
didn't like that i think i was attempt
that humor for me
and look at his team look at his teeth
and two he already
downtown tickler so he's already like
being sexual what does a tickler mean
he's going to eat her [ __ ] edit that
out
edit that out um he has nice teeth
you could tell he takes care of himself
he kind of has his [ __ ] together yeah
he probably watches the show so he's
trying to be funny so he's through
something true
but a firefighter yeah what he's
responsible
he's got money he's a manly man he cares
about the um you know
he's first team all man yeah he's a
guy's guy well he's in the lead right
now it's good to me
so maybe uh uh get your notes app open
just so you can remember these guys
because we got six
first and what was that first guy's name
there's six of them you told me five
nick
uh well we got a late submission that i
i like
[Laughter]
he comes after [ __ ] captain america i
mean
you should have opened with this guy
yeah who's the non-keto gentleman from
[ __ ] alabama here
so i know this is a no-go for me no no
no no no he looks nice he's a nice guy
pretending
the chance pretend they didn't say that
we're gonna bring up another one real
quick
okay here's the thing he looks friendly
what up brandon what up theo rest of the
king and stink crew
uh this is jake i'm also from southern
idaho
just trying to connect with savannah i
already slender dms
i've never met her we follow a lot of
the same people i have a lot of the same
friends in common
um so number one reason it'd be cheap
for you guys to send us on a date we
don't even have that expensive
restaurants out here uh number two
i got that theo vaughn hitter yeah i
love his head hopefully i'm like
a quarter as funny as theo maybe she'll
like me um
but it's not me theo i hope you marry
her so
see you guys this is a nice guy
he has gentle eyes i kind of i know who
he is
oh you don't know who he is already he
messaged me we have the same friends
oh so you already run in the same pack a
little bit um
sort of not really but like i know who
he is
so really really nice those are two
solid dudes
yeah he's nice you might be too nice she
don't want him
she don't want a nice guy here's suitor
number three i can't say that all right
so this guy
okay he's been in a few bar fights i
like this guy all right what's up
my name is on nick post on instagram we
can win a date with you
you're an absolute perfect 10. so i
thought [ __ ] it shoot my shot
um why i think you should go on a date
with me i'm a short king
if you ever want to be big school i'm
down for that
i know uh you said you were getting
wanted to get wiped up but that guy
didn't want to wipe you up i'll [ __ ]
take you to vegas right now
and watch you up after that guys doesn't
know what he's missing
um i'm italian i know how to cook i know
where to get good
food um i i like to think i'm fun and i
get to hang out with comedians so right
now i'm not funny but hopefully by the
time we meet
i'll be a little funnier and have a
little experience um this isn't that
great of a video
uh if i saw this i wouldn't want to date
me but [ __ ] it
good that was good oh he's the best guy
so far yeah for sure
for sure 100 are you just saying that
because he said he's short
no he's he's a real guy he knows how
that's the thing she remembers the most
yeah i was gonna say are you into short
guys
no she wants somebody to give up not
necessarily no
that's a no not necessarily you're into
that firefighter
i need to feel like they're taking care
of me i don't want to be like
eye level with them i'm short myself
this kid looks scrappy though this kid
looks strappy
he's got a great body strappy great body
he looks scrappy
great body okay great body
yeah stevie you want to date him
it sounds like he's more like stevie's
type okay he's going different with it
now
this is this is gavin tread lightly
oh no hey savannah this is gavin from
beautiful boise idaho
i know you said you're from south idaho
so i don't know you go a little too far
east or west from there
from here and uh dudes with pigment
aren't totally allowed but we can always
get through that
that's just one step um i think you know
getting out of a four-year relationship
that's tough uh
figuring out going through your whole
face or you know getting back in a
relationship
i say come out here to boise let's go to
barbacoa rooftop bar
let's go to i don't know let's say
roddy's ride the bull
and then we can figure it out from there
uh besides that
i think you're a beautiful girl and i
think things could really work out so
gang gang buzz buzz what are these the
nicest guys ever
you guys seem super friendly well
they're all from idaho aren't they
yeah so far guys
an out here a half away from boise
that's not bad
yeah i'm in twin falls so eric likes him
because it looks like he's standing
oh there's jeremiah
to come from the peanut gallery there he
is
dude that could he could play you in a
prequel or definitely good no what do
you think
i don't see it i don't see it i see
that guy had the most uh i think he had
he i think he came at you
like hey he was real i i think you have
the most fun with him
and also he seems super nice yeah he's
nice
i i kind of try to put priority on the
guys who seem serious about it
and then but yeah he also he gave you a
giveaway of
the pigment of his skin so are you into
black guys
i haven't ever dated a black guy but i
wouldn't rule it out
don't get her started on short black
guys oh my god
but it would be short would be the
problem first or black
yeah problem first
imagine if you're short like how [ __ ]
up that is
you're telling me like if you're short
you're like i can see you're saying it's
black it's discrimination right now like
if you're
if you're if you're a racist short guy
like if you're a really
racist short guy you just got kicked in
the next [ __ ] this
[ __ ] show man uh this is drew
all right hey what's up savannah this is
drew from aspen colorado
i saw your video and wanted to tell you
to
keep it tight don't hoe it out
and have some fun you know get out there
meet some people
you know maybe myself my really cool dog
this guy's a snowboarder but he's sweet
um and i have hair too by the way so
it's not just
a cover-up but either way
i think you're beautiful young lady and
clearly quite intelligent
so you should find somebody equal to you
you know and that young man you were
dating was uh
definitely not there so keep it tight
keep it right um come hang out in aspen
this guy needs a monster energy drink
yeah his energy
yeah she wouldn't like his dog either
because uh he's short black
fair point oh my that is so not what i
meant
he seems nice though he does seem nice
from aspen that aspen that would be a
nice place to go visit that's for sure
guys
we got one more yes yeah it's tough to
beat that firefighter so yeah
you're the first guy can we start off
with a bang
what's up guys my name is andrew i'm 29
years old from minnesota
and i'm shooting my shot with savannah
i love a chance to talk to her meet up
with her whatever
um i'm a physical therapist i
pretty much i have my own house and i
got my life put together all i need is
that
that special lady in my life now um
yeah she looks beautiful looks amazing
looks like a fun time and
um looks like a girl i would get along
with
and um you know either way
if she wants a ride or die i'm husband
material but if she just wants to have a
good time
i'm a good time so either way
you can count me in what's pretty much
means i own my own house
i pretty much own my own house well he's
waiting for his mom to die yeah
i mean not technically but okay this is
this the last one
yeah i'ma say this though huh he got the
most swag
okay like he could tell you're leaving
yeah yeah yeah there's girls in
minnesota for him yeah yeah yeah so
this if i had to pick it would be
firefighter
all day you know firefighter's a home
run girl yeah
this one and i trust him we don't set
you up on a date and
you know the dudes of psychopath and
maybe go on a date with the short guy
and the black guy at the same time
really mix it up
will she be able to look at him okay
yeah i think the first wait i won't ever
be able to no you will
yeah but i think those two the first one
and the last one i think are your best
friends
things miss [ __ ] this guy's in minnesota
yeah minnesota i
a that's a strike for me but i other
than that
he sounded really great but don't you
want to get out of there you all your
don't you want to leave idaho you think
i want to go to minnesota
instead okay fair point in manhattan
uh i i i like the first two guys i
thought the second guy
looked real sweet he's real nice the guy
who knows all your friends
with the theo von mullet he looked cool
the firefighters the i mean the first
guy
i think the last well the first the last
guy is in minnesota just out you don't
even gonna take a chance
no no i think minnesota i think the
first one and the last one are on my top
two
so okay where are we at on a low energy
aspect
yeah honestly he was a three star in my
book
he was very low energy you're right too
low energy yeah i mean come on
yeah okay the first guy is is roland
down here have you did your email
rolling
all right we're going to let in andrew
right now which one was andrew he
this guy the the player from minnesota
oh okay
so we're gonna we're gonna bring in both
guys he just assume he's a player
you guys said he had he could take it or
leave that's what i think he is in
minnesota
he's a physical therapist yeah so but
it's all right
what if i told you there's something out
there where you spend money and get
rewarded
for good money habits i'm talking about
credit karma credit karma money is brand
new checking account
we can win cash and reimbursements for
making purchases
when you use credit karma money debit
card you can win
instantly karma purchase reimbursements
on items up to five thousand dollars
just pay with your debit card and if you
win you'll be notified on the spot
of your instant karma cash and will be
added right back into your spend account
credit karma
money has already been given away over
three million dollars in instant karma
to over 50 000 credit karma members and
counting
all right only for july 1st through july
23rd and when you make purchase between
july 1st 23rd you'll automatically
enter to win 1 million dollars credit
karma money
progress starts here right now visit
creditkarma.com win money to open your
free account and start winning instant
karma
go to creditkarma.com win money to sign
up for free start winning instant karma
that's creditkarma.com win money
instant karma is sponsored by credit
karma no purchase necessary exclusions
and terms apply
see rules banking services provided by
mvmb bank
incorporated member fdic maximum balance
and transfer limits apply again that's
creditkarma.com
win money this episode of king this
sting with eric griffin and my boy
stevie is brought to you by bluetooth
bluetooth is making waves
bringing more confidence in the bed man
have you ever been with your girl
like man i could really use a boost
right now while i got you covered fellas
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
true will form at a fraction of the cost
you want to get your piece up and also
not break the bank blue chews for you
combats all forms of ed helps you gain a
little extra confidence in the bed when
it's time to go bluetooth is the online
prescription service
no visits the doctors no awkward
conversations all right no waiting line
at the pharmacy ships right to your door
discreet little package sign up is easy
go to bluechew.com consult one of their
licensed medical providers
once you're approved your prescription
shows up within days best part it's all
online we've got you covered man
it's made in the u.s of a so if you
could benefit from a little actual
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluechew.com for more details
important safety information
and i have one hell of a deal for you
try blue chew free when you use the
promo code kats
at checkout just pay five dollar
shipping that's bluechew.com promo code
kats to receive your first month
free and we thank blue chew for being
part of the king and the sting
podcast hello yeah can you hear us
yeah i can hear you sweet say hi to
savannah his mask though
i'm in the
that's right now he's burlier than i
thought look at you yeah
early i'm about to say he's like he's
bigger
he's bigger than i thought
he took a fence he showed his body in
the mirror already like yo yo yo yo yo
i'm in shape
how how big are you boss i'm like
6 feet 200 pounds solid dude oh wow
oh wow yup solid bicep diameter
how tall are you what would you say
savannah savannah are you a short queen
i'm like five two that's cool
yeah all right and 120
so okay
so we're gonna bring in the other two
guys they don't have their name on their
zoom so one of these
is not roland um
and who's roland the firefighter
just just the two that she likes okay
sorry gavin you weren't picked i gotta
damn what's up interesting
that and this current assignment
really evolved in this climate you want
to you want to do it like this correct
that's how you want to do it
i like this guy
look how friendly he looks man and the
other guy left so he's staying in all
right
the firefighter might have to fight a
fire the firefighter left
yeah maybe hey what's up guys yo
what's up man what's up dog
[Music]
[Laughter]
so this is gavin christian you guys
wanna uh just go back and forth asking
him some questions get to know gavin and
christian for savannah
christian yeah fellas what would you do
on the first date with savannah let's
say you came to idaho what would you do
first date
you want me to go first go ahead man
yeah so i'm already out night oh i would
say
uh a good date would be probably
starting out at barbacoa which is like a
super nice restaurant down here
rooftop bar
he has qriket wireless that's yeah
that's that's right that's a strike
that's the messiah
and then after that
okay there we go oh there we go right to
t-mobile
are you headed to t-mobile right now
because all right all right i said we
would go to uh barbacoa a nice little
restaurant out here
start out there get some drinks uh
head over to the silly birch which is
one of my other favorite bars maybe play
some pool um and at the end of the night
try and hit up like a comedy show or a
concert or something like that because
everything's starting back up out here
yeah sounds good that actually sounds
really nice i'm not gonna lie
[ __ ] i'll go out there he trying to get
rid of
hey brandon you want to come out here
too bro it's fine i know man
uh what about you mike is a good time
boys he's a great time great time no i
love boise
well we actually got an update from from
roland uh he was unable to join because
he's currently fighting a fire in utah
i [ __ ] knew it oh wow i love that guy
you don't have time for that he's the
one
i'm saving lives tell those other clowns
and hey even if i won on a technicality
i'll still be in here
i like it and you you're doing a good
job so far you're still in there uh any
questions for andrew
andrew uh first date man you're
minnesota so i guess we'll fly her to
minnesota
what are we doing you know i would just
like to take her on a nice
dinner and just get to know her and um
respect her and if the night leads to
something else at least something else
if not
that's fine this guy's smooth you are
well he's putting it on the table yeah
so something else what are you saying
like what's something else like you know
what what would something else look like
to you
it could be big it could be small i
don't know
well she's hoping it's big
[Music]
and i'm just throwing that out do both
do both of you drink
yeah yes i do everyone here drinks
what kind of food like me like italian
food like what kind of restaurant
yeah what do you guys have in minnesota
yeah we got everything i probably bring
you to a mexican restaurant
hey let me ask you fellas this why are
you two single what
was the last relationship
i'll go first again uh i actually just
recently got out of one i was told that
you know they just want to be friends so
you know i don't think there's anything
to it i just think
i think it was just you know it just
wasn't the right time was in the right
place
i have an idea have them take their
shirts off let's see your physique i
like it stevie
can we have them show their physique
their physique
they're muscles well one they want guys
at work so yeah
i mean go in the bathroom yeah because
you know i'm definitely at work
i'm gonna let that work and what about
i'm not trying to let stevie weeby see
any of this
that's a fair place
let me ask you fellas this what's what's
the worst thing you've done to a
girlfriend
cheat what like what are we talking
about here
the worst thing yep
i think i love them too much you know
smooth man oh man take your shirt off
man good
answer take your shirt i feel like we're
on family feeling right now
okay
[Laughter]
what about what about you my man
physical therapist what's going on with
you
i don't know man i'm a good guy i'm a
genuinely good guy i haven't done
i've had my heart just stomped on before
oh yeah what you my last relationship i
was pretty
emotionally abused so i guess i'm kind
of damaged goods maybe
but
she's so excited i love a project and
fellas is savannah your type is she the
typical
girl you'd go for yes
what dope yeah yeah what are you saying
right they're in
they're in i would say yes
yes she is i'm from the northern part of
idaho so there's you know there's only
white girls up there so you know i'm
used to them
so you haven't met a lot of dads then
right
[Laughter]
at least not mine
[Laughter]
see he's he don't want me over i don't
know
i love this guy he don't want me on me
too man he's already in idaho
[Laughter]
well savannah where where where where's
your hat on this we were you thinking
yeah what questions do you have
what questions do i have i didn't
prepare any questions i was told that
you guys were just going to roast them
for me
but from what you've heard so far does
it just
like does nothing come to mind do you
like what you see i mean
say something i do like what i see i do
like what i see actually both of them
seem very nice they both seem um
like the type of guy that i would date
actually uh the one in boise i'd
probably run into actually
minnesota that's that's the one that's a
little more intriguing to me because i
i wouldn't run into him anywhere but so
who's getting the rose
yeah if you have to give one of them a
rose what are we doing here savannah
yeah what are we doing i'm just getting
your idaho potato
i would have to say it's the one from
minnesota i'd have to say
that if you get frozen shocker oh i'm
hurt
gavin don't give up though just dmr in
the right write it
yeah just find my ideas
other girls are going to see this man
and you're a cat yeah man yeah you're a
good dude
man because i i you you'll be able to
the top of my list yeah you
yeah until the fire is over hey thank
you hey brandon are you coming back out
here for another show brother
yeah we'll figure it out man we
appreciate it though man thanks for
playing
uh and and guess what peace out y'all
gavin do we have uh your permission to
put like your instagram handle on the
screen so
so girls can dm you yeah of course
hell yeah wow he's ready i like this guy
really good dude good job man
thanks gavin well cool just you two
maybe we'll work
it out and try to yeah we'll set
something up yeah we'll we'll
off here we'll set it up we don't want
you blast out your information on here
yeah yeah but please request please
record everything except
especially the big stuff
you have a busy work schedule huh she'd
have to come there where only weekends
are open for you
pretty much just weekends yo savannah
you're busy out in
idaho um yeah but weekends are free for
me
all right all right there we go we'll
figure it out job man they look like a
couple yeah
yeah they already look like this is
gonna work out gonna be the first king
in the state wedding
second second we've got uh we've got a
couple that we introduced living
together oh wow oh that's right
uh carly eat it back you eat it eat it
do you know that chin yeah carly got a
man i'm telling you
it worked out everything worked out
perfectly kind of well thanks
thanks for joining guys yeah thank you
thanks guys
hopefully that helps good luck yeah you
know what's crazy
it's like you know the one guy he's nice
he was winning somebody she was charming
yeah she was like no i still want the
hot white guy from my from minnesota i
don't think
it wasn't but it's so much more
difficult to be with i want to be with
that guy
the guy who said nothing the entire time
he said nothing i was selling it the
other guy was
working man did he say he took a [ __ ]
too
yeah no he was saying he was in the
[ __ ] is what he said oh
yes because he he was at work at work
he seems like a serious dude the other
guy was fun friendly had a whole date
that way well the fire guy should have
you know with the fire in the background
what's up girl you know i'm saving lives
i don't have a lot of time but i'm in
[Laughter]
the phone just drops and you ah he's
standing over going like this
let go everyone everyone
move move move what would get him
somebody yeah the firefighter was the uh
the catch there yeah well this guy's oh
i think they're minnesota guy minnesota
guy was dope dude he seemed too
into it did he well he's at work but
still dude the other guy was at work
he was outside the other guy wasn't at
work he said he was yeah he was walking
around too much
we didn't ask him what he did did we uh
we didn't but he was at work and he
asked his boss that was his lunch break
and at first he's like i don't know if i
had enough
time but then he just like broke it to
his boss and he's and his boss was like
go for it man all right good
man i like that guy yeah hopefully find
something you know what you're gonna you
know what you have to do you're gonna
have to bring him back on and get some
girls for him
that's a lot harder yeah getting female
suitors that watch the show but yeah
yeah yeah well heavy mail demo here yeah
uh this is gonna be rough transition but
should we get in some kinder stuff yeah
bring it
brendan squabs and theo von helsing
it's delby from perth here just want to
king it'll sting it
people that are on their phones when you
talk it on the worst thing i'll sting it
huge thing there's nothing worse than
when you go to like a restaurant
somewhere even on the road i don't know
how you do it
like when you're in the green room and
you're like back there and you know
you're getting ready to go
and everyone's just glued to their phone
i'm like god damn
put your phones down man can we just pay
attention experience
life right now what did he even say i
don't even know what he just said
i don't know what it was about either
steve that's just basically he's saying
people
say people when you're talking and
they're just on there staring at their
phones oh
it's this question i don't even know it
like are you cool with it are you not
cool with it
is that what he said yeah oh man he's
not from here
okay i don't know that's a sting a sting
would be
so like workaholics days it would be
like tight butthole or loose butthole
exactly so that's loose butthole
but there's nothing to me there's
nothing more insulting when you're
having a conversation
and then they're texting because i can't
talk in text you know goddamn well
they're not listening
because you got those big ufc fingers
[ __ ] delinquents shout out from texas
got a kang understanding for you
crawfish do you eat that ass or not
anyways king you're staying it gang gang
drug bust truck bus that's a thick-ass
car okay
thank you right here's my problem i
don't know if he's
buff or is he a fat cop because i can't
stand getting pulled over by a fat cop
nothing more i'm gonna have some
self-respect yeah
because if if you don't have that gun
and i take off right now you sure as
[ __ ] not catching me
when i know and you know what the in
shade cops they can't stand the fat cops
no hell no hell no he's a big bone guy
yeah but no he could actually he could
just be like
you know what i mean he could be swole
that face begs the difference
and the crawfish in the in his squad car
yeah yeah question about yeah
live crawfish that he's got in a tank in
his car
that yeah that's what was this question
again eating crap
you struggle with english honda confused
being on you like where are these people
from and like what are they
why are they asking these things man
it's the show dog so withdrawal
what's up with crawford is it like
crawfish lobster like it has nothing to
do with anything it's just so easy
you're gonna eat the blood of the
crawfish that's his question well the
the crawfish they say
we used to i used to work with that you
got steve irritated i know man
he's got a fair i don't want to arm
wrestle you right now yeah we can arm
wrestle
yeah yeah if you want
hold on hold on i don't wear it i don't
know
hold up hold up hold up i've been
training i've been watching
youtube videos me and jeremiah have been
training
hey bring jeremiah in here real quick
for for armor no no for a challenge i
i want to i want you i don't wrestle you
jeremiah arm wrestles him why am i
getting in this
jeremiah get in here make any claims i
didn't either what are you talking about
no i just i don't like your energy right
now yeah
yeah the crawfish what triggered you
yeah
everything's triggering me right now
chin are you cool is it a korean thing
are you cool fish come on in here
yeah a lot of asians eat crawfish that's
what i thought
there they are there they are hey what's
up so i had an idea of
we've been watching youtube videos on
arm wrestling
why for this moment oh okay
like over the top with sylvester
stallone exactly exactly
exactly so we have a scissor bros
challenge
i arm wrestle you he arm wrestles you
whoever the loser whoever the loser is
we have fart spray what do you do with
that
whoever the loser is has to huff fart
spray
in a ziploc bag in a ziploc bag wait
fart breath or stevie's uh fart spray or
stevie's breath
is the thing kaboom
[Laughter]
bullseye
got me was ready for that one so what do
you guys say
is that the same guy who just got turned
down by that girl he's a good guy
but he's are you amazing 130 pounds
i mean if he wants tb remember i didn't
ask for this man
i know but i want you to try your
hardest okay
so your arm wrestled me sure right there
it's just like you're in a bar
and like a little dude comes up to you i
could take you yeah all right yeah
so i'm just trying to enjoy you see i'm
just trying to enjoy my beer bro
okay so i'm gonna walk you over there
we've been really training hard for this
you guys been training on your show for
this yeah i've been doing curls and what
have you been doing jeremiah
a lot of tricep stuff so do you think
you could take eric i can take eric for
sure
oh god yeah it sucks because if theo is
here
you probably have a better chance at
theo i feel like eric's gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of you
jeremiah you think so yes but we would
have to inhale
fart spray yeah the loser has to inhale
fart spray for five times like what do
you say five times maybe just once so
five times
yeah i'm not doing that no don't then
don't
then don't lose how are you setting the
rules
this is just a one-time deal right as
far as
one time should we just get out of the
way
in case stevie wins
come on steve you got this dude come on
put more body into it
i didn't ask for this
okay
don't do anything you're not comfortable
with but i am curious who's going to win
this
i'm i'm kind of into this matchup
yeah this is a good man
yeah don't let him don't let him yeah
what are you doing so i'll go three
two one go all right turn the might turn
the microphone forwards towards them
yeah what are you talking about
you can't stand up oh he's sitting down
i'm leaning over the table though
okay was more than that
okay okay ready three two
one go oh no
no
talk about your all-time backfires i
mean
i don't know what they thought was going
to happen
hit the showers fellas hit the farts
[ __ ]
don't spell it in the room don't smell
out in the room yeah yeah yeah you can't
do it in here
what do you mean we have to do it in the
bags you spray it into the bag
into the bag we're gonna even buy
something like that
someone sent it to us where do you where
do you buy where'd you who bought this
jeremiah someone sent it to us
really yeah like hey fellas here's our
fart spray yeah
you know what i should have done is i
should have brought my riffing with
griffin theme song
and done my podcast here too
[Applause]
we're fair losers okay are we doing this
that's good dude get it before it [ __ ]
up the room
and this is what you guys do on your
show all the time
yeah oh they do a lot of weird things
oh god they're naked and everything you
guys what oh it's going to stink huh
it's horrible do you guys want to try it
yeah make sure you shut down
and try it no okay we won all right
completely self-inflicted by them
excuse me yeah they weren't gonna
i really thought i was gonna beat eric
did you
i was excited for the matchup i thought
you know i don't know
yeah okay oh thanks for calling me in
yeah thank you guys
i'm gonna give this a sting
[Laughter]
you sting it you're sticking it i'm
stinging it
here's another topic that's apropos of
nothing
thick boy bike club candidate edition
got a
tangent or stinger for you boys
let's think about that backside rider
[Music]
well that gets a king yeah you got a
king it was just him
sting for sure you agree yeah you know
because he's got farrah fawcett's hair
on his beard yeah you know what i mean
but yeah king
i remember i used to ride with my dad
but it was like he had one of those road
bikes and it was just a little seat on
the back
it wasn't like an extension like that
that's some new age [ __ ] yeah
i was on the back like but he's so big
though that he could be riding his bike
and he could be like
you okay back there and then she's
already gone like she's you know i mean
he's a good dude definitely king king
good dad
yeah i guess we'll keep the relationship
stuff going
this guy's looking for some advice
hey what up brandon what up theo this is
uh stephen allen houston texas
out here fixing ac units man i got a
relationship advice for y'all man
uh brandon i know you like them big
booty latinas
it's hard to stay away from i got me one
two turn into my baby mama man
but uh i was wondering uh during
arguments
are you guys the type to stay quiet and
let her get [ __ ] off her chest
um or do you guys argue back man because
i know any time i argue back
i always end up losing and i end up
having to apologize even though
i know damn right i'm right you know
what i'm saying so
just trying to see what you guys do
during arguments or either type to keep
cool and stay quiet
or do you argue that [ __ ] back and let
her have it man let me
know that's that latino man you know
what you're signing up for let me go
ahead and put this out here
to all the guys because look what he
just said
this is let me ask you a question do you
want to be right
or you do you want to be in a happy
relationship don't be right
well and then that's why i argue yeah
you gotta get like a [ __ ] episode of
law and order dude
it is one of those it's on you like doo
doo doo
doo doo doo doo you just clocked in
[ __ ] you got it because here comes the
defense
you got her in the tree you get us some
what you need some water first before we
start
is this about to get real in here yeah i
know it's like you have that
i'm argumentative by nature so it's
tough it's really tough for me to just
you know
comic is like it's tough yeah it's just
like and you can pick apart and you talk
for a living so it's like really
yeah and then there's she's like all
right i'm i'm done because you just pick
apart everything
yeah you can't do that no no i don't i
don't advise it especially with a latino
man then when she started talking [ __ ]
in spanish i'm like right
keep that attitude up he started
handling it right it's like you don't
need here's the thing he knows what he's
doing if you know you're right
that's all you should need that's it
true if if you can be like okay
all right but but our problem is we want
her to acknowledge that word you're a
mature ass dude though like it probably
took you a while to get this oh yeah
like stevie i feel like you're not
you're not putting up an argument no
no i'm not definitely your arguments go
like that arm wrestling match yeah yeah
but you get quiet your thing is probably
just to shut down no i've
fought i've had my fair share of fights
but yeah you just got it
this is like jeremiah and i had a baby
[Laughter]
theo brennan what's up it's your boy
willie j on the test 200 back at you
and i got to ask you guys about some
relationship advice is this the woolly
willy guy that we played last week
uh-huh i've never seen this guy met this
girl she's a physician's assistant she's
a little bit older than me
and you know we were just hanging out
whatever
and she was like yo i'm not having sex
until i'm getting married
i like her a lot a lot of good things
going but
kind of refreshing the first girl i've
ever dated like that so what what
someone had to do
you know we got a lot of roanoke girls
out there they thirsty as hell
gang gang buzz buzz first of all
what is this guy's eye prescription
because those bifocals
yeah those things that [ __ ] is
yeah
he gets see through the walls with that
[ __ ]
no but but obviously he said the girl's
older so she's obviously has made a new
choice in her life because the other
[ __ ] wasn't right
moving forward i'm not doing this i
think that's too extreme
yeah i think it's extreme but i think
it's okay to have like a
two-month three-month or some kind of
thing yeah i'm cool with that i'm cool
with that but like
to be like we're not gonna do it until
we get married it's like yeah i don't
buy cars unless i test drive yeah you
gotta
yeah at least smell the inside it was
something
i gotta kick the tires a little bit you
know so what was this question oh my
gosh
he's he's high on fart spray
who said uh like let's say you guys hit
it off but she was like i'm not having
sex
i get married so what you want to do
it's a tough one huh the toughest yeah
it's like you're beautiful
who you're not gonna have sex with you
know like so whoever you're gonna get
married to but what about our sex
no doubt but if she was a dime piece
you'd wait
no you wouldn't if she was like a 10
you would wait oh i don't know think
about it oh i don't know
tremendous personality like a young man
like a penthouse model or something
like this if a penthouse model is making
you wait
come on girl okay yeah you're right yeah
young haley berry is a good one
right flintstones movie right that's
tough though i mean i i think it's
extreme
she probably has been through some stuff
some major [ __ ] maybe she's just testing
him too
yeah oh that's the other thing maybe
yeah that's a test yeah she says go
along with he sticks around she's like
you know you stuck around
you can have it yeah that's how it's
gonna go down you can hit it after three
weeks
who's this young gentleman nick he's got
a king at her sting it for us too
what's up brendan what's up theo shout
out culture corner this is cody out of
indiana
you recently had somebody um ask if you
would be comfortable
living next to a cemetery well what are
your thoughts on working with the dead
i cremate people i bury people i make
headstones and i install headstones
all year round rainshine sleet snow i'm
in the cemetery almost every day
ass crack of dawn till late at night
so yeah what are your thoughts working
with
the dead king it or sting it i'm
sticking this right now
gotta keep an eye out god bless somebody
automatic sting you're getting it
you gotta have all these on a button
yeah
one of my own roommates right we grew up
in a haunted house me and bob no
hey what was the question again yeah
he lives you deals with
like he works at uh he works at a
mortuary right now
you know he told me but he hurts a good
business because obviously people are
dying all the time yeah that's what he
was saying it's like it's all
cozy people it's like that's about going
you know you're worried about if you're
going to get it from this like surreal
man i'm stinging it to myself
you don't want to mess with that with it
yeah have you ever been around i
remember a good a buddy of mine had died
he drowned
sadly and you know you know he was in a
hot they had his body in the hospital
and it's just
when you see someone like that it's it's
it messes you up yeah man
it's too dark yeah i mean bob almost got
possessed by a ghost at
our powerhouse like he had to jump in
the swimming pool to get
them off of him now were you guys doing
drugs at this time
no my first thought no come on no
how much acid did bob take no it wasn't
he was on our acid because they
tried to get me too they held me down
and he
whispers on both sides you got held down
by the yeah by the ghosts they're like
oh that's kind of
you sure this wasn't like a 51 50 call
no
how old were you guys elementary school
middle school
sixth grade seventh like fifth sixth
seventh grade or something like that
yeah i had bible verses in my room too
yeah and they still attack me yeah i
don't mess with it well this guy's
trying to attack somebody
who's this guy uh i thought we'd close
out you're staying at robbing banks
look we'll watch a couple of the
submissions that didn't get picked for
savannah
uh this was this guy's attempt
these are the help
this message is for havana young lady
won't know if she should go through her
whole face
yes savannah please go through your
whole face please stop begging
where do you get that mask every man in
america is begging you need to go
through
this is how you not waste the code and
there's really no better city to begin
your host phase than
right here in the beautiful city of
nashville home of country music
more recently theo vaughn kid rock lives
here
i know them all it's gonna be snowing
all summer
so have mick or lynn get you my digits
and if i have some numbers on my prepaid
booth sweetie when you call i'll answer
it i promise you
chance of him being on theo's next
episode in nashville pretty good
yeah that's true i should hit him up
this guy also submitted oh yeah this is
the best guy here
theo brandon gang gang buzz buzz you
guys are big inspirations
and make a smile put a smile on my face
every day but uh this
mission is for savannah you know i'd
have to say keep it tight let's go
find that forever one i'm over here and
then nom
uh i'm looking for a girl to write some
letters to hopefully come home too
uh you know
yeah it does not look like vietnam those
are basically two best ones i felt like
they had to be seen they had dudes those
are too good
to show yeah
yeah well fellas thanks for coming in
man
uh housekeeping notes oh uh my shows for
san antonio
just went on sale september 24th 25th
bud light courtyard right outside att
arena where the spurs play
just went on sale tickets at
thickboy.com
uh pre-sale ticket code is thick thick
with three c's first tickets to san
antonio
on that july 16th july 17th ha has
shop and friends uh we're doing two
shows friday two shows saturday
take us at thickboy.com there as well
hey guys sorry i couldn't be there this
week i'm a little bit under the
weather and uh speaking of mixed
feelings
i want to thank eric griffin for being
there and
uh stevie
you were also there and brendan
as well says brendan i want to let you
know that i'll be coming to st
louis cincinnati charlotte durham
chattanooga knoxville and some shows
also now in portland maine and
burlington vermont
wilkes-barre wilmington minneapolis
charleston richmond
baltimore albany columbus a lot of new
shows on sale for the cities that were
sold out and thank you guys for
supporting uh king and the sting i'll be
back next week
gang [ __ ] baby go poirier
is this uh coming out today thursday
thursday oh
i'll be in uh the comedy zone in
jacksonville
if you want to come there will you do
your uh just get tickets at your website
yeah yeah yeah cause i got the link on
my website or girlfriend.com
schedule check out riffin with griffin
and eric griffin on twitch
yeah and twitch watch me game and and
please also
check out scissor brothers thank you
please
steve if the arm wrestling if the armor
tube doesn't tell you
yeah yeah if the fart smelling and the
and the the the
doggy pony show that just uh subscribe
today
hit subscribe youtube.com yeah and
jacksonville get your ass to sierra
griffin man he's a monster
yeah come check me out appreciate you
guys man yeah thanks buzz
thanks for
[Music]
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
brendan ate the queso and the quesoritos
but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tripping couldn't beat him
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want the smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brendan's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in a club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you